i
y
[Música]
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su programa
sobre la actualidad francesa en esta
edición hablaremos desde must sobre el
reciclaje de colillas de cigarrillo
luego de la preocupación de los
panaderos por el alza de los precios
debido a la inflación de regreso aquí a
parís descubriremos que es la museo
terapia y terminaremos en gijón para
celebrar el arte de la buena mesa
francesa
[Música]
cada año más de 23 mil millones de
colillas de cigarrillo terminan en las
calles del país en la ciudad de paja
está hay una empresa que el azar
recolecta y las recicla a gran escala y
con ellas fábrica luego mobiliario
urbano que pone después en venta pero
antes tienen que eliminar las más de 250
sustancias tóxicas que hay dentro de una
colilla de cigarrillo en este siguiente
informe veamos cómo se realiza todo ese
proceso
100% reciclado
estos objetos fueron hechos en una
innovadora fábrica la única que trata
este tipo de residuos en francia
estas son las colillas de cigarrillos
que nos enviaron y desde aquí pasarán
por un proceso de clasificación y
descontaminación cigarrillos recogidos
en las calles o en las playas esta
empresa ha reciclado más de 50 toneladas
desde 2017 el tabaco puede recuperarse
rápidamente para hacer compostaje pero
las colillas tienen un alto nivel de
toxicidad se descontamina en estos
grandes toneles sin duda
el agua de lluvia permite mezclarla y a
medida que se mezclan se expulsan los
contaminantes como la nicotina los
hidrocarburos y el formaldehído todos
los contaminantes de los cigarrillos y
pulió como les haya hecho una vez que
está limpia la fibra de las colillas se
comprime a altas temperaturas para ser
convertida en placas de plástico que
serán la base de futuros asientos y
ceniceros urbanos
llenas de ciudades en francia ya han
hecho sus pedidos lander no fue la
primera en las estaciones de buses
varios bancos fabricados por la empresa
esperan a los usuarios blogs deben decir
este es un asiento simplemente hay que
sentarse aquí y esperar el pulso para
cuando llegue el bus uno se va y tiene
la satisfacción de haberse sentado sobre
miles de cigarrillos vendidos a las
colectividades por trescientos euros el
alcalde instaló los asientos en
diferentes puntos de la ciudad gracias a
esta iniciativa la cndr no obtuvo la
etiqueta cero colillas una primicia en
francia
inicialmente que hicimos ubicarlo en un
lugar simbólico como la estación de
buses donde uno suele tirar su último
cigarrillo el suelo queríamos tratar de
que este mobiliario fuera visible para
mostrar que las colillas son un material
y que con ese material se puede hacer
algo pero para reciclar este material
primero hay que recolectar lo
este cenicero mural será instalado en la
fachada de esta tabaquería los
funcionarios municipales pasarán a
recoger las colillas una vez a la semana
un servicio totalmente gratuito
haciendo propietario de una tabaquería
es importante reciclar las colillas que
se venden y también hay que intentar
hacer algo por la naturaleza algo más ya
se han instalado 70 ceniceros en los
lugares más frecuentados de la ciudad
una iniciativa aplaudida por sus
habitantes puri por higiene para recoger
las colillas que están tiradas por todas
partes me parece que es un buen
procedimiento baila un software capaz
conmigo táctil
y
la empresa espera poder duplicar la
cantidad de mobiliarios urbanos en las
próximas semanas ante la emergencia
ambiental tan solo el 0 2% de las
colillas tiradas al suelo cada año se
revaloriza el costo de la vida es
noticia diaria con una inflación
galopante en los supermercados el precio
de los productos no deja de aumentar sin
embargo los panaderos del país varios de
ellos tratan de encontrar astucias para
no repercutir el alza de las materias
primas en el precio del pan veamos en
este reportaje cómo ha logrado hacerlo
cada baguette vale un euro y por la
compra de tres la cuarta es gratis estos
atractivos precios son en gran medida la
razón del éxito de esta red de 200
panaderías presentes en las zonas de
mayor actividad
pero cómo mantener este rango de precios
frente al aumento de los costos de las
materias primas
montelongo recomiendo una cosa que para
mí se está votando para enfrentar esta
problemática los dirigentes han tomado
decisiones redujeron los precios de los
envoltorios sacrificaron una parte de su
margen pero se alegran por haber
negociado precios fijos para la harina
justo antes de su aumento hemos tenido
la suerte de negociar contratos desde
hace unos 10 años con nuestros
agricultores para los siguientes tres
años entonces ahora con la harina
podemos neutralizar una parte del
aumento es importante porque es lo que
nos permite mantener el precio de la
baguette pero otros no cuentan con la
misma suerte
salvamos este panadero independiente
paga cada vez más por su harina y para
que esto no repercutiera en sus precios
se le ocurrió una idea suprimir los
envoltorios de papel para el pan camps
nos acostumbramos cómodamente a esos
pedazos de papel para evitar llenar de
migas el auto o para que fuera más fácil
transportar el pan pero al hacer el
cálculo el papel equivale en realidad
del precio de la harina de lázaro y los
clientes aprobaron esta novedad es una
buena idea se desperdicia menos papel
cada uno trae su envoltorio está muy
bien panaderos astutos que encuentran
soluciones para no aumentar el precio
del pan por ahora ha funcionado pero
habrá un límite en particular si
continúa el aumento inédito del precio
de las materias primas admirar un lienzo
de moneda o una escultura de moda para
tener buena salud en francés los médicos
no solamente están prescribiendo a hacer
deporte para mantenerse saludable sino
que también están recetando el arte como
cura es una idea que viene de canadá
pero que se está probando en francia y
aquí en parís hay varios museos que
están recibiendo gratuitamente a los
pacientes remitidos por sus doctores en
el siguiente informe veremos cómo y por
qué el arte es bueno para la salud el
doctor monta lescott recibe una paciente
que tuvo un infarto
ward un estrés que no se ha ido y que
puede representar un riesgo de recaída
con sí
para calmar esa ansiedad el médico le
receta una visita gratuita al museo
ahora recitamos visitas al museo le
decimos a la gente que vaya al museo
donde tenemos una guía voluntaria que
les muestra hermosas obras de arte que
les provocarán una sensación de placer y
de relajación de camps y de amplias y en
la sesión
claudine escogió monet en el museo
marmottan se encuentran con otros
pacientes todos enviados por sus médicos
[Música]
una asociación de pacientes paga las
entradas françois la guía les mostrará
los nenúfares como nunca los han visto
empiezan con un ejercicio de relajación
iguales 2 y según los pacientes esta
técnica funciona con mi vida cotidiana a
veces puede ser bastante angustiante por
la enfermedad cardíaca y me parece que
esto es bastante tranquilizador
como en medio del torbellino de la vida
son momentos de repliegue y de calma de
calma cómo actúa una obra de arte sobre
nuestro cuerpo
este cardiólogo y esta neuropsicóloga
nos proponen un experimento
monitorean la frecuencia cardíaca y nos
piden que observemos una obra de arte
esta es una hermosa pintura de degas es
un paisaje contempla un poco la obra la
obra de arte actúa rápidamente
su corazón empezó a latir más despacio
probablemente usted pasó a estar en un
estado mucho más sereno y eso no es todo
y además hay una liberación de dopamina
que sirve para combatir la hormona del
estrés tras este hospital de lyon
también utiliza la fórmula de los museos
con sus pacientes más jóvenes
tomás de 11 años acaba de ser operado de
una peritonitis esta psicóloga le pide
que escoja un cuadro que su madre va a
buscar al pasillo
tomás escogió este colorido paisaje que
ahora estará colgado en su habitación
lowe matthew que reunió las obras está
convencida de que este cuadro ayudará a
que tomás se recupere desviando su
atención
estimulará su capacidad para soñar y
cuando uno imagina olvida el lugar en el
que está los médicos quieren convencer a
los museos de recibir gratuitamente a
los pacientes que lleguen con una receta
tanto son los beneficios que puede tener
el arte sobre nuestra salud la ciudadela
de la gastronomía y del vino abrió sus
puertas en el show después de varios
años de obras y una inversión de unos
250 millones de euros la ciudad cuenta
con un lugar turístico y cultural
hagamos entonces un recorrido por este
lugar que exalta no solamente la
gastronomía francesa sino también los
viñedos de borgoña ambos inscritos en el
patrimonio mundial de la unesco
un templo para la buena mesa y el laudo
y dijo a franceses eso es la ciudadela
de la gastronomía y del vino que abrió
sus puertas en la ciudad división su
objetivo es contar y explicar de manera
vivida que es precisamente la
gastronomía francesa incluida en la
lista del patrimonio inmaterial de la
humanidad de la unesco por supuesto es
una fiesta de nuestra gastronomía y a
través de nuestra gastronomía reconocer
el trabajo de quienes la hacen nuestros
productores nuestros artesanos
viticultores arte de la mesa y todos
aquellos que están alrededor de esta
gastronomía
esta fiesta se vive en un espacio de 6
hectáreas y media en el antiguo hospital
del espíritu santo fundado en 1.204 esta
ciudadela es un recorrido a través de la
historia de la mesa francesa con
exposiciones sobre la repostería los
viñedos de borgoña y la cocina pero
también es un punto para degustar
delicias culinarias en dos restaurantes
a cargo del chef tres estrellas
efectivas y probar entre las más de 3000
referencias de vinos de la tradicional
región vitícola
y el hecho de buscar mostrar sus vinos
de arriba abajo es para mostrar toda la
diversidad de los viñedos perdón de los
climas de aumento de clima para lo que
llamamos clima son las tierras los
terran de bourgogne y en esta misma
pared se puede ver toda la variedad de
vinos
de nueve boutiques ofrecen productos de
panadería dulces y carnicería y allí
está también una sucursal de la
prestigiosa escuela de cocina ferrandis
aquí los chefs están en plena
preparación de la tradicional milhoja
y se necesita mucho rigor cantidad de
conocimiento conocimiento compasión
porque se necesita tener pasión es muy
importante entender lo que ocurre con el
conocimiento y luego la práctica
práctica práctica
este ambicioso proyecto inició en 2013
por iniciativa del entonces presidente
françois hollande su costo fue de 250
millones de euros en su mayoría de
fondos privados
mayas es deslumbrante haber logrado este
maridaje entre por supuesto la
gastronomía el vino claro pero también
la cultura la pedagogía la educación la
formación y el desarrollo local porque
creo que esta ciudadela es la primera
pero seguro la más brillante
yo te digo y este nuevo templo esperan
acoger un millón de visitantes por año
aunque un proyecto similar fracasó hace
un tiempo en lyon se espera que en los
próximos años habrán ciudadelas en tour
y parís
hasta aquí esta edición desde francia en
foco gracias por habernos acompañado
continúen con nuestra programación en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]